Speaker 1: It's time for the Friday mailbag, let's
get to it, if you have something to say, hopefully
something substantive, hopefully something
relevant to the audience. Hopefully something
related to things that have actually been said
on the show, unlike many of the emails I get.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com. Don't
abuse it. Don't send too many emails or you'll get
blocked. We'll start today with this is a little
bonus. This one is actually from Facebook. I'm
sorry. This was from YouTube. This is from Rob
Rob, who says David Pakman hates the God bless
the USA. What a loser. Now this. This could mean
one of two things, and this relates to the I've
told you guys that something about Trump rallies
in 2022 is really triggering to the Trumpists.
I would cover Trump rallies in 2017. In 2016, I
would cover Trump rallies leading up to the 2020
election, even in 2021. Those weird Trump rallies,
the Trump is didn't really care about my coverage.
They didn't seem triggered by it in 2020, too.
Every time I cover a Trump rally live, I get a
deluge of YouTube comments, Twitter replies and
emails from people furious with my coverage. Now,
this could mean one of two things Rob might mean
that I hate the USA, which of course I don't
or rob might mean I hate that terrible
country song that Trump plays at every rally
that ends. God bless the USA or starts that way or
is called that I don't even really know. I don't
like the song, so it could mean one of two things.
I don't know which it is, but I appreciate hearing
from Rob as always, Jeff wrote. To me, this is
fascinating. Jeff is a former Trump supporter,
and Jeff wrote to me and said, Mr. Pacman with
great respect. I voted for Donald Trump twice.
I was a moderate Republican with left social
views, and I didn't realize just how much Q Anon
had infiltrated the party until January 6th. As a
result of that, and I really like Kirsten Cinema
and Jared Polis. I will be voting with the
Democrats until this rot has been removed.
I'm worried about Democrats and independents
not voting this fall because they might
be mad about inflation and other issues. What
can I as a betrayed Trump supporter, do to help
get the anti-Trump vote out in 22 and 24? Phone
bank. Phone. Bank, phone. Bank. Phone Bank. For
any candidate that you believe is a sort of sort
of a swing district, an important seat in 2022.
Jeff also said, I figured out about Trump's
demagogery on my own. But your show has helped
me become more comfortable with the left.
Thank you, Jeff. This is a beautiful email.
Great to hear from Jeff about this issue,
and this is, you know, this is a reminder
this stuff matters. People listen to this and
we do have an impact. It is great to hear. Now
I know a lot of you will focus in on, as you can
see here, where Jeff says he likes Kirsten Cinema,
and I know my progressive audience really doesn't
like Kirsten Center. I don't focus on that
focus on the fact that this is someone who
voted for Trump twice, who now is not voting
for Republicans. That's still a good thing. Next
e-mail is from Ray Ray. This one's actually from
this one's actually from YouTube. Ray Ray said
David says he doesn't care about Bible quotations
and then quotes the Bible and gives passage
location as a Jew. David has not followed
King David and yielded his will to Yahweh. He has
rejected Messiah and the propitious Asian offered
by Jesus as a blood sacrifice for sin. He is a
child of wrath and unredeemed, a rebel against
Yahweh, and one of them a lawyer asking him a
question, testing him. Teacher, what is the great
commandment in the law? And he said, You shall
love the Lord, your god with all your heart and
with all your soul and with all your mind. This
is the great and foremost commandment. OK, this is
out of control. Crazy, but the one part I want to
address is. Do people understand that when I say.
I don't care about the Bible, but for people
who do. Here is what it says. That is, I think,
clear to most people, and the context was Madison
Cawthorn, Madison Cawthorn had wrongly quoted the
Bible and what I said was, I don't care
what the Bible says one way or the other.
I don't care. But Madison Cawthorn claims to
care and his followers claim to care. So for
the people that do care? Here is what the Bible
actually says it. You guys understand that, right?
That's not it. That's not a double standard.
Ray Ray, you got to get it together, my friend
Brandon wrote in about accountability. And Brandon
wrote, David, I was wondering, why are Congress
members allowed to lie without consequence all the
time? Is there a way to hold them accountable for
these lies, such as a policy that makes them
come clean after proven to be wrong? To me,
that just seems like a normal courtesy of everyday
people. Thanks for your thoughts. Yeah, I mean,
listen, brand is not wrong. It would be great if
more elected officials did what I do on the show,
which is when I know I've gotten something wrong,
not buried on the bonus show at the top of the
show, I will say, guys, I got something wrong
yesterday, gals. I have to make a correction.
But anything beyond that actually could
potentially violate the First Amendment.
So I'm not I'm not sure exactly what you have in
mind, Brandon, but as a show of common decency,
it would be great for elected officials not to lie
as much and when they get things wrong to correct
them as quickly as possible. Lauren Rhoden about
trans rights and critical race theory. Lawrence
said, Good evening, David, this question may be
a bit ignorant, and I've tried to read up on it
without a veil. My question is, is trans rights
part of critical race theory or are these two
different issues? I assumed critical race theory
was solely race related. But I hear all of these
people associating them as the same issue. I
appreciate your perspective. Thank you for being a
logical voice in this illogical world. So, Lauren,
let me give you two answers. The first answer is
everything can be related to any fight against
injustice can be related. And to the extent that
supporters of critical race theory and supporters
of trans rights believe that both are frameworks
for giving people rights and beat them up, it all
could be related. So I know that if I just say
these are two different issues, someone will
say David, sir, or they might be less polite,
you're being discriminatory by claiming that
these are unrelated issues. Now, my opinion is
these are unrelated issues. So you can always
find some thread to link things together. You
can link together, you know, Mandarin oranges
and, you know, nuclear energy. I don't know.
I'm sure you could. But but these really are
two separate things. Critical race theory
is a subset of critical theory, critical theory,
a great framework for understanding literature,
a great framework from the mid 20th century for
thinking about a lot of different things and
critical race theory specifically wants to apply
that to our understanding of race and society,
and different people have different opinions on
it. I'm not like big on critical race theory.
Critical theory. I find fascinating postmodernism.
I find fascinating. OK, etc. Fine. So that's
critical. Race theory at trans rights is about
trans rights, and it relates to equality under
the law. It relates to the bathroom stuff. There's
the sports element of it. There's who can sue for
gender discrimination. And that came up during
the Katagiri Brown Jackson hearings. So again,
with the idea that CRT concerns itself with rights
along race and trans rights released the trans
rights, you could say there's some thread there.
But yes, you're not wrong, Lauren, that these
there are two separate issues here. Swift wrote
in about Social Security and Medicare bankruptcy.
So it says Mr Pacman, sir, I've been told many
times by many people that Medicare and Social
Security are going bankrupt on your show today.
You mentioned this is not true. Can you please
elaborate on this? So I understand better, OK?
So there is a difference between going bankrupt
and headed towards insolvency. Bankruptcy is.
That's it. You're out of business. You can't
pay Medicare. Being bankrupt means they can't pay
for anybody's health. Health care, Social Security
being bankrupt means there's no more Social
Security benefits for anybody if nothing is
done. With cost of living, growing and baby
boomers retiring, Social Security could get to
the point where if nothing changes, they wouldn't
be able to pay their full benefits to everybody.
OK, so what does that mean? You have to do? Well,
there's a couple different ways you could do it.
You could reduce benefits. You could
make people wait longer to retire
or you could collect more money. And one of
the simplest ways you can fix Social Security's
insolvency that would eventually come and
eventually is you raise the cap on which
Social Security tax is collected right now. You
only pay Social Security tax on roughly your
first hundred and thirty ish thousand dollars.
So if you make $200000 a year that lasts 70 K,
you're not paying into Social Security at
all. If you make a million dollars a year,
you that last eight hundred and seventy k, you're
not paying into Social Security. So there's some
really small tweaks that could be made to fix
the insolvency issue. Similarly, with Medicare,
with health care costs rising, baby boomers
retiring, etc. If nothing is changed,
Medicare could become insolvent, which means
it would have it would have a budget crunch,
not bankruptcy. Really important to understand.
Not a subtle difference, Jim wrote in about the
Will Smith smack and said, Do you think the right
wing is upset about Will Smith because they're
confusing Chris Rock for Kid Rock? As as funny
as that is, Jim and I have not heard that before.
I actually don't think that's the confusion,
but I love the I love the idea. Very,
very clever. And lastly, Patrick wrote in, and
Patrick says question. Watch your show sometimes
curious. When are you going to discuss Hunter
Biden's laptop? Like to hear your comments?
We will talk about Hunter Biden's laptop
when there's really something to talk about.
There is an investigation into Hunter Biden's
business dealings. They don't relate to the
laptop, and I already covered it. That's really
the story. And Hunter Biden has nothing to do with
the Biden administration, so there's not too much
to say about it. But if there's something to cover
about Hunter Biden's laptop and if Hunter Biden
becomes relevant to what's going on politically?
Joe Biden something something relevant. Be sure
that I will be covering it, my friend. No question
about it. That's going to do it for today. We
have a tremendous bonus show coming up for you.
Become a member. Sign up at join Packman dot com.
And remember, if you already have a membership,
you can now gift memberships to others. Just go
through the signup process, check the box that
says this is a gift. We have 600 people waiting
for memberships who have requested memberships.
Make someone's dream come true.
Gift a membership at Join Passive
Income. I'll see you on the bonus show.